♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGIN, A FOX NEWS ALERT.
IF YOU MISSED IT, AN AMAZING
TOWN HALL IN PENNSYLVANIA HERE
TONIGHT ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
WE HAVE THE HIGHLIGHTS AND ALSO
BREAKING TONIGHT, WE ARE ABOUT
TO REVEAL SOME DISTURBING,
FRANKLY REPUGNANT AUDIO FROM
QUID PRO QUO JOE ON
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, ON WOMEN.
FROM HIM AS A YOUNG SENATOR PAIR
THAT IS MOMENTS AWAY TONIGHT.
PLUS, NUMBERS DO NOT LIE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S MASSIVE, HUGE,
RECORD TURNOUT ON SUPER TUESDAY
SET NEW RECORDS, BROKE ALL
EXPECTATIONS.
REMEMBER, THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
IS NOT CONTESTED.
PRETTY AMAZING NUMBERS YOU WON’T
GET FROM THE MOB.
ALSO COMING UP, WE WILL ANALYZE
THAT, KARL ROVE IS A BOARD AND
WE WILL HAVE THE VERY LATEST
FALLOUT FROM CAPITOL HILL WHERE
YEP, CHUCK SCHUMER, THAT GUY IS
IN BIG TROUBLE TONIGHT OVER THE
THREAT OF VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT
TWO U.S. SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
NOW HIS APPALLING BEHAVIOR MIGHT
ACTUALLY LAND HIM IN SERIOUS
LEGAL JEOPARDY.
WE WILL EXPLAIN THAT STRAIGHT
AHEAD.
FIRST WE START WITH SOMETHING
YOU WILL NEVER SEE IN THE MEDIA
MOB, THAT ARE ABUSIVELY BIASED,
TOWARDS THE PRESIDENT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO VET
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT WILL BE A LONG PROCESS
BECAUSE IN THE NEXT 243 DAYS,
YOU WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY
AND WE WANT YOU TO BE AS
INFORMED AS POSSIBLE.
THEY NEVER VETTED OBAMA.
WE DID.
THE MOBILE CIRCLE THE WAGONS
AROUND THE CHOSEN ONE.
THEY WILL ACT LIKE HIS GAFFES
MEAN NOTHING.
IT’S NOT A BIG DEAL, THEY WILL
IGNORE IT.
THEY MIGHT ALSO IGNORE HIS
RECORD, WHICH IS ATROCIOUS.
AND MANY OTHER THINGS.
WE WILL COVER IT ALL ON THAT
SHOW.
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER THEY WILL DO TO PROTECT
JOE BIDEN AND SHIELD HIM FROM
ANY NEGATIVE COVERAGE.
SO IT’S UP TO US.
THAT IS OUR JOB.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THIS
CAMERA EVERY NIGHT TO HELP
INFORM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OF
SERIOUS PROBLEMS SURROUNDING,
YES, FORMER VICE PRESIDENT QUID
PRO QUO JOE.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THREE ISSUES THAT SHOULD CONCERN
EVERY AMERICAN VOTER.
ONE, IT IS THE LEGITIMATE
QUESTION OVER WHETHER OR NOT A
77-YEAR-OLD BIDEN HAS THE
STAMINA AND THE STRENGTH, THE
MENTAL ACUMEN AND FOCUS REQUIRED
TO SERVE IN WHAT IS THE MOST
DIFFICULT JOB IN THE WORLD,
PERIOD.
NOW WE HAVE COVERED THIS ISSUE
IN DEPTH LAST NIGHT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, BIDEN IS
STRUGGLING.
IF HE HAD A FASTBALL, IT’S GONE.
IF HE HAD A SLOW PITCH, THAT IS
GONE TOO.
HE IS CONFUSING AND BUMBLING
SPEECHES, INCREASING NUMBERS OF
GAFFES, PUBLIC OUTBURSTS ARE
BEYOND TROUBLESOME.
MOST PEOPLE SEE IT.
THE MEDIA MOB IS TRYING TO
IGNORE IT.
THE ISSUE NUMBER TWO SURROUNDS
QUID PRO QUO JOE IN THE ISSUE OF
CORRUPTION.
THERE ARE NOW MULTIPLE ONGOING
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATIONS OF
THE U.S. SENATE.
RON JOHNSON OF WISCONSIN LEADING
THE WAY THEY APPEARED IN THE
COUNTRY OF UKRAINE INVOLVING
SHADY BIDEN’S ACTIVITY THERE.
YOU’RE NOT GETTING THE BILLING
UNTIL YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING LAZIER EXPERIENCE
ON PAID MILLIONS.
THAT DOESN’T JUST GO AWAY
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO GO AWAY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRACK THIS
ONGOING SCANDAL.
BIG INVESTIGATION ALSO GOING ON
IN UKRAINE.
WE WILL FOLLOW IT WHERE FOR THE
TRUTH LEADS TO.
WE WILL FOCUS ON BIDEN’S THIRD
MAJOR ISSUE.
HE HAS A TRACK RECORD.
BY THE WAY, I WOULD SAY
78-YEAR-OLD BERNIE, HE HAS THE
ENERGY AND STAMINA.
A LOT MORE THAN JOE BIDEN.
BUT THE 77-YEAR-OLD CAREER
POLITICIAN, FIRST ELECTED TO THE
U.S. SENATE IN 1972 HAS A LONG,
DICEY PUBLIC HISTORY, WHICH
BRINGS US TO OUR SHOCKING NEW
AUDIO.
THIS IS MAY 18TH, 1973.
TRY AND LISTEN TO THIS THROUGH
THE PRISM OF WHAT IF
DONALD TRUMP SAID IT.
SENATOR BIDEN GAVE A LENGTHY
SPEECH TO THE CITY CLUB OF
CLEVELAND.
WE HAVE CONFIRMED WITH THEM THAT
THESE ARE IN FACT HIS REMARKS.
IT WAS ALSO COVERED BY
Cleveland.com AND BREITBART,
AND OTHER NEWS SOURCES.
HE BRAGGED THAT POLITICIANS WERE
MORE MORAL, MORE MORAL THAN
DOCTORS THAT SAVE OUR LIVES,
LAWYERS, AND EVEN INDIAN CHIEFS.
CAN’T MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> POLITICS SHOULD BE THE MOST
HONORABLE OF PROFESSIONS.
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE DOCTORS AND
LAWYERS AND INDIAN CHIEFS IN THE
AUDIENCE, HOW CAN ANY OF YOU
POSSIBLY DO AS MUCH GOOD IF YOU
ARE VERY GOOD AT WHAT YOU DO AS
I CAN DO IF I AM VERY GOOD AT
WHAT I CAN DO?
>> Sean: THAT IS PRETTY
ARROGANT.
I DON’T THINK THEY DO MORE
DAMAGE THAN IN THE SWAMP.
BIDEN WENT ON TO CLARIFY HOWEVER
HE WASN’T A PARTICULARLY MORAL
PERSON HIMSELF.
INTERESTING ADMISSION FEE OR
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I FORTUNATELY HAD OVER 3,000
INDIVIDUAL CONTRIBUTORS.
NOBODY MAKES UP ANY MORE THAN 1%
EACH POINT OF MY TOTAL BUDGET.
NOBODY FROM ONE PERCENTAGE POINT
GETS A HOLD OF THAT EITHER.
NOBODY GETS ANY MORE THAN A
RETURN PHONE CALL FOR THAT 1%.
BUT IT’S NOT BECAUSE I AM
PARTICULARLY MORAL.
IT’S BECAUSE NOBODY TOOK ME
SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: BIDEN ADMITTING HE
WILL PRETTY MUCH DO ANYTHING TO
MAINTAIN POWER.
WOW.
BUT THE MOST SHOCKING PARTS OF
THE AUDIO INVOLVE HIS STATEMENTS
ABOUT WOMEN AND MINORITIES.
HE MADE SEVERAL DEROGATORY JOKES
AUDIENCE.
HE DIDN’T EVEN THINK, OH, THEY
TOLD ME YOU WEREN’T GOING TO BE
HERE.
I WASN’T EXPECTING YOU TO BE
TAKE A LISTEN.
SPEAK OF THE ONLY ANALOGY I CAN
REALLY THINK OF IS A FOOTBALL AN
AND I APOLOGIZE TO YOU WOMEN IN
THE AUDIENCE FOR NOT BEING ABLE
TO THINK OF A MORE APPROPRIATE
ANALOGY, BUT THEY TOLD ME HERE
THEY DIDN’T WANT YOU HERE
ANYWAY.
I DIDN’T EXPECT ANY WOMEN TO BE
HERE.
>> Sean: I CAME HERE TO TALK
FOOTBALL WITH A GROUP OF GUYS,
YOU CAN’T POSSIBLY KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT FOOTBALL.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF ANY
REPUBLICAN SAID THIS?
THE HYSTERIA IN THE MEDIA MOB
WOULD BE NONSTOP.
APOPLECTIC OUTRAGE, MORAL
SELECTIVE OUTRAGE AS IT USUALLY
IS.
HERE’S ONE MORE.
AT ONE POINT IN THE SPEECH BIDEN
SINGLED OUT A WOMAN IN THE FRONT
ROW ASKING HIM A QUESTION.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> SENATOR, I FIND YOU VERY
ARTICULATE.
>> I FIND YOU VERY CALMLY.
SPEAK OF THE REST IS NOT VERY
GOOD.
[LAUGHTER]
’S BECAUSE THAT’S I THOUGHT.
THAT’S WHY I TRY TO COMPLIMENT
YOU, I THOUGHT I WOULD SCARE YOU
OUT OF IT.
>> TO THE BEST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE
KNOWLEDGE, HAS THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY EVER BEEN INVOLVED IN
SOMETHING IS ATROCIOUS AS
BUGGING?
>> SURE, YES, YES I DO.
BUT BUGGING ISN’T THE QUESTION,
KIDDO.
>> Sean: OH, KIDDO.
THEY DIDN’T WANT YOU HERE
ANYWAY.
THIS GUY IS TRYING TO WIN OVER A
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
AND THERE’S MORE.
AT ONE POINT SENATOR BIDEN
ACTUALLY REFERS TO
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN WHAT I SEE
IS A HORRIBLE, DEGRADING WORD.
LISTEN FOR YOURSELF.
>> I THINK THE TWO PARTY SYSTEM,
ALTHOUGH MY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
COLLEAGUES DON’T LIKE ME SAYING
THIS, I THINK IT’S GOOD FOR THE
SOUTH, GOOD FOR THE [BLEEP],
GOOD FOR THE SOUTH.
>> Sean: WE REACHED OUT TO THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN FOR COMMENT AND
THEY HAVE NOT RESPONDED.
ACCORDING TO THEIR RULES YOU
MUST BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR EVERY
WORD YOU’VE EVER SAID AND DONE,
UNLESS OF COURSE YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT AND YOU BLEED WITH
THEM.
YOU MIGHT ALSO WANT TO REMEMBER
JOE BIDEN, EVEN IN THIS SPEECH,
HE PRAISED UNKNOWN
SEGREGATIONIST AND GET THIS,
Cleveland.com FIRST REPORTED
THESE DISTURBING REMARKS IN MAY
OF 2019 AND I DOUBT ANY OF YOU
SAW THIS UP UNTIL NOW AND NEARLY
EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
IGNORED IT.
OF COURSE THEY DID.
BIDEN MEANWHILE HAS A LONG
RECORD OF WEIRD, OFFENSIVE AND
FRANKLY RACIAL RHETORIC.
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD IS NOTHING
NEW.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE LARGEST GROWTH IN
POPULATION IS INDIAN AMERICANS
MOVI FROM INDIA.
YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR A
DUNKIN’ DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I’M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT KIND OF A CHANCE WOULD A
NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL LIKE
JOE BIDEN STAND IN THE SOUTHWEST
MARKET >> BETTER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU DON’T KNOW MY STATE.
MY STATE WAS A STATE, THE EIGHTH
LARGEST BLACK POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> FIRST SORT OF MAINSTREAM
AMERICAN WHO IS ARTICULATE AND
BRIGHT AND CLEAN, AND A
NICE-LOOKING GUY.
>> THEY’RE GOING TO PUT YOU BACK
IN CHAINS.
>> Sean: FIRST TIME EVER,
BRIGHT AND ARTICULATE AND CLEAN.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THIS IS ALL STORYBOOK.
WHAT?
YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
BIDEN ONCE REFERRED TO OBAMA AS
THE FIRST MAINSTREAM
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO IS
ARTICULATE, BRIGHT AND CLEAN.
WHY IS THE RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LINING UP BEHIND A VERY
DEFAULTED CANDIDATE WHO ALSO
PRAISED SEGREGATIONIST QWEST
MARKET APPARENTLY NOW THEY HAVE
NO CHOICE.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS OFFICIALLY
OUT.
NO ONE LIKED HER AND THE OTHER
CANDIDATE JUST SPEND WEEKS
DOUBLING DOWN ON HIS PRAISE OF
MURDERING COMMUNISTIC
DICTATORSHIPS.
MOMENTS AGO DURING A FOX
TOWN HALL, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ON HIS A-GAME TONIGHT.
HE OFFERED HIS OWN ANALYSIS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC RACE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU WANT TO FACE JOE BIDEN OR
BERNIE SANDERS?
THAT IS MY QUESTION.
>> I WAS ALL SET FOR BERNIE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WE GET READY FOR THINGS, RIGHT?
MENTALLY, I AM ALL SET FOR
BERNIE.
COMMUNIST, I HAD EVERYTHING
DOWN.
HE IS ALL THAT.
I WAS ALL SET.
AND THEN WE HAVE THIS CRAZY
THING THAT HAPPENED, RIGHT, ON
TUESDAY, WHICH HE THOUGHT WAS
THURSDAY.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT HE ALSO SAID 150 MILLION
PEOPLE WERE KILLED WITH GUNS,
AND HE WAS RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
TO SUPPORT ME, RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE IS SOMETHING GOING ON
THERE.
I WAS ALL SET, I WAS ALL SET FOR
BERNIE.
I WAS READY TO GO.
THEN I SAID, YOU KNOW, I DON’T
THINK I’M RUNNING AGAINST BERNIE
BAIRD AND NICK IT’S GOING TO BE
VERY HARD FOR HIM TO COME BACK
>> Sean: IF YOU ARE A
JOE BIDEN SUPPORTER AND YOU
DON’T HAVE A FASTBALL IF YOU
EVER HAD ONE, YOU DON’T OF A
SLOW PITCH, YOU WATCH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO ARE YOU
GOING TO BET ON IN THESE
DEBATES?
THE PRESIDENT IS SPOT ON.
BUT THE SOCIALISTS SHOULD BE
HAPPY EITHER WAY BECAUSE HERE’S
THE POINT I MADE ABOUT SUPER
TUESDAY THAT NO ONE ELSE IN THE
MEDIA MADE.
IN THE LEAD UP TO SUPER TUESDAY,
BERNIE SANDERS WAS DOUBLING DOWN
ON DEFENDING MURDERING DICTATORS
AND THEIR REGIMES.
CASTROS, FORMER SOVIET UNION,
USSR, DANIEL ORTEGA, VENEZUELA.
OKAY, EVEN DEMOCRATS, WE CAN’T
DEFEND MURDERING DICTATORSHIPS,
SO.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
BERNIE AND BIDEN, THEY ARE FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN AND WE’VE GOT
THE TAPE.
THEY BOTH SUPPORT THE NEW GREEN
DEAL, THEY BOTH SUPPORT OPEN
BORDERS, THEY BOTH SUPPORT FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, THEY BOTH OPENLY
VOWED TO RAISE YOUR TAXES.
THEY BOTH WANT TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS IN THE
LIST GOES ON AND THEY HAVE
EXTREME POSITIONS ON ABORTIONS.
IN FACT, 2016 VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN SHOWERED BERNIE SANDERS
WITH PRAISE.
I JUST WISH HE DIDN’T CALL
HIMSELF A SOCIALIST BECAUSE
EVERYTHING ELSE IS GREAT.
HE ALL BUT ENDORSED BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE IN 2016 AGAINST HILLARY.
HERE’S THE VIDEO.
>> IF BERNIE SANDERS NEVER SAID
HE WAS A DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST,
BASED ON WHAT HE IS SAYING,
PEOPLE WOULDN’T BE CALLING HIM A
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
THAT IS HOW HE CHARACTERIZES
HIMSELF, AND SORT OF EUROPEAN
TERMS.
A DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST, THE
PARTIES IN EUROPE.
SPEAK ABOUT WHY IS SHE HAVING
TROUBLE?
>> I THINK BERNIE IS SPEAKING TO
A YEARNING THAT IS DEEP AND
REAL, AND HE HAS CREDIBILITY ON
IT.
>> Sean: DEEP YEARNING.
AT 203 DAYS, ASK YOURSELF ARE
YOU BETTER OFF NOW THAN YOU WERE
FOUR YEARS AGO?
THE OBAMA-BIDEN TRACK RECORD,
THE RADIAN DEAL, 13 MILLION
MORE FOOD STAMPS, LOWEST LABOR
RATES SINCE THE 1960s.
DID YOU THINK THAT WAS A GLOWING
SUCCESS QUEST ERECTED THEY
FULFILL THEIR PROMISE?
DID YOU KEEP YOUR DOCTOR?
DID YOU KEEP YOUR PLAN?
BECAUSE MILLIONS OF THEM LOST
THEM.
HOW DID THE IRAN DEAL GO?
HOW MUCH MONEY DID AMERICAN SAVE
ON HEALTH CARE?
DIDN’T SAVE A LOT, WE ARE PAYING
200% MORE FOR HEALTH CARE IN THE
COUNTRY.
DID THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IMPROVE OR WORSEN?
IN 243 DAYS THIS IS THE BIGGEST
CHOICE ELECTION IN OUR LIFETIME.
THAT IS JUST A FACT.
THE GOOD NEWS TONIGHT IS THIS:
THE SHEER ENTHUSIASM FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THIS IS THE
UNTOLD STORY OF TUESDAY.
SUPER TUESDAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DROVE OUR RECORD
NUMBER OF VOTERS TO THE POLLS IN
CONTESTS THAT WEREN’T CONTESTED.
LOOK AT THIS IN TEXAS.
HE GOT MORE VOTES THAN BIDEN,
BERNIE, AND WARREN COMBINED.
IT WAS AN UNCONTESTED ELECTION.
IS THE MEDIA REPORTING THAT?
HE RECEIVED MORE VOTES THAN
VERMONT, MINNESOTA,
MASSACHUSETTS, TENNESSEE THAN
ANY INCUMBENT IN THE LAST FOUR
DECADES.
COLORADO, TERM TURN OUT WAS GREA
THAN THE LAST THREE REPUBLICAN